first let's talk about the Iceland based  airline wow it's called  we hear that it's shut down so what does  that mean for people that have  reservations with Wow well Wow is a  discount carrier offering fares to  Europe from four US cities for as low as  a hundred bucks this shutdown will  strand thousands of Flyers around the  world if you have a reservation the best  option for you is to call your credit  card company and try to get a refund  that way also if you're flying wow and  you're stuck somewhere airlines  typically will off your offer rescue  fares those will be discounted fares to  get you home but you'll still have to  come up with money out of your pocket  Gail well not so Wow today thank you  very much Chris